posez-le complètement en verre au-dessus
les lits sont couchés, les fenêtres et le verre
et le fils est déjà à l'hôpital et l'appartement
toutes les portes entièrement vitrées
videur
tout est détruit
Je veux transmettre à travers toi ce que c'est
créature créatures russes naturelles créatures et
créatures mais est-il possible de faire cela ?
baiser la maison des personnes âgées
A mon avis, pour Odessa si tel
le coup de malade n'est pas humain, c'est seulement
les créatures et les animaux peuvent le faire
à la veille des vacances lumineuses de Pass
féliciter la ville orthodoxe d'Odessa
aujourd'hui est probablement dans l'esprit de Poutine et de son
meutes d'animaux